absolution along doughnuts we got Jeff
from Oklahoma City yeah praise God
OKC and look at that main bro gang gang
buzz-buzz yeah what's going on is Jeff
here from Oklahoma City just high as
[ __ ] got a debate club topic for yes
Jeff use elevate important yes mr.
Brendan Schwab dog when you're flying on
a commercial airline flight are you
grabbing that muff are gonna window seat
are you looking for that [ __ ]
aisle seat word good question anyways
you know what it is Gang Gang Bulls
[ __ ] boys boys do that whiskey sales
ah bro here's the thing I'm a Road Dogg
I'm on the road non-stop I'm window only
bro I know you been a Road Dogg for 17
years
way to go way to go I'm on the window
bro so I can snuggle up get a nap in the
aisle
I'm way too thick for the nobody getting
drinks by sin the aisle if there's an
emergency no one's getting out I take up
too much room bro they actually asked me
sit in the window oh you're the tall
little cam dude I wouldn't put you on
the [ __ ] aisle for nothing bro I want
to put you in the mercy I say yeah and
I'm like [ __ ] no I'm getting down first
if you hand me one baby I'll take him
but I wait and employee
yeah you better come with that baby with
that quickness
yeah dude if you sitting in the back
like some [ __ ] some lazy fat adaxel
dude then you're going down you're going
down with time bro you're falling in the
time down science bro I go windows man I
like being by the window - one time - I
was on a flight it was a small plane and
they we hit a goose or something with
the propeller and it bounced down the
side of the plane and it was pretty cool
you could just right down the side and
when we got there and parked it was when
we had to get out on the jet onto the
tarmac and walk out it down a little
stairs and they had the goose feathers
in the prop and I had a little bit of
blood on
side see that's entertainment you didn't
have to pay for and that's hunting bro
depends where yeah you could have ate
that bird yeah that's some same put a
net on the back of this [ __ ] and less
eat when we land that's not a bad idea
little barbecue in your land Gang Gang
boys in the front in the back all right
let's keep it let's keep involving 5%
went with the window as well dude here's
the thing - what savages be farting on
the plane we all got a breed that ear
and bro I want a guy up once said Joe
you got to stop though you're sitting
front of me yeah you have to
oh I shook him I said I know what you I
didn't what'd he say I said I know it's
you and he cuddly he said I know it's
you that's the Lord's work and that was
it dude and he stopped after that he
done it 11 times right dude and his
[ __ ] wife was sitting next to me
could tell that he beat his wife and
never let her have a say say it [ __ ] you
could tell she'd never said anything
she'd been smelling probably thousands
of him and then I saw him at the [ __ ]
baggage check out and I'm [ __ ] looks
downright well look fart magnet yeah you
[ __ ] hot anymore the bomber what's up
bro
yeah dude I hope somebody farts in your
[ __ ] casket broccolini
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching